Who is the real Pewdiepie?...
A question Scientist have bee asked for centuries....
Isn't that right fake PewDiePie?
Fake Pewdiepie: Yes, real Pewdiepie, that is right
That is right
So many impostors
What if one of them... steals my girlfriend, Marzia?
That would break my heart
Let's review... the samples
HOOO
Hey
That is unlicensed pewdiepie merch
How many times do I gotta say this?
(dramatic music)
Da fuck is this
Ain't no party like a pewdiepie party
snapback
WHERE DID YOU BUY THIS?!?!
ANSWER ME DAMMIT
How did I miss... How did I miss from this distance?
Fake Pewdiepie: I got it on EBAY for $3
It was a great deal!
God damn unlicensed Pewdiepie merch, when will you stop buying into it?
You call this the Pewdiepie logo?
Jesus Christ
There's even intricate guidelines
On how to impersonate Pewdiepie
You... you need some lightning
And some tight pants
(Mysterious music)
This one's trying steal underage women.
Why you - What the fuck
So much wrong with this
KEEMSTAR NOPE SHUSHHHH
THAT IS NOT ME I PROMISE
Why do so many girls want to dress up as me
HEYY THAT'S IB!
That's kinda cute!
That's kinda cute...
Those fucking shoes man,  Jesus...
Why is it so common to try and steal my identity?
Who are-  OOOOOOOOOOOOOOH...
Why?
Why do these people, keep trying?
THE FUCK IS THIS?
Oh it's that impostor guy
It's that guy wiith a-
He's gotta big chin tho
Big ups for that man!
That is a nice fuckin' chin!
*NoChin Intensifies*
Actually...
Can I just say something?
*Sad Music*
Look at this...
Alright.. it may not be a big chin.
But it's a chin
Let's not say that it's no chin cause its definitely a chin
If it wasn't a chin it woulda looked like-
different
Now, what's wrong with small chins?
There's nothing wrong with small chins.
Stay the fuck out of my boy leafy
Just cause you don't have a chin doesn't mean you're not a man
What the fuck is this?
Fake PooDiePie *gangnam style playing in the background*
Fake Pewdiepie: Is that a fake Pewdiepie? *gangnam style playing in the background*
That's right, that is a fake Pewdiepie, fake Pewdiepie *gangnam style playing in the background*
That fake Pewdiepie is really good at dancing tho *gangnam style playing in the background*
*Cringenum Style Intensifies* *gangnam style playing in the background*
Oh boy *gangnam style playing in the background*
That's talent. *gangnam style playing in the background*
That's real talent!
Oh my God this guy is pretending to be Pewdiepie!
WHAT THE FUCK?
Impostor Pewdiepie: *inaudible*
Impostor Pewdiepie: *chuckle*
Oh my God, THESE PEOPLE ARE FALLING FOR IT!
I DON'T TALK LIKE THAT!
THAT AIN'T ME!
THAT'S NOT ME I SWEAR!
OOOOHHH!!
OH MY GOD, HE'S TRYING TO GET LADIES
He's trying really hard not to look at her tits...
WHAT THE FUCK AM I WATCHING?
Oh wow!
That looks...
That looks just like me.
I can't tell any difference.
That looks really good.
That looks very-
That's my classic face
Well...
Well I've seen it all now.
I've seen it-
I've seen it all
Thank you
OOOOOOOOOOOOOHHH...
*beep*
These fake Pewdiepie
Is trying to ruin my rep!
Not just underaged girls...
but also the KKK!
I have so many questions about this photo.
I don't know where to begin.
What the fuck?
And what the fuck?
Look how fucking many there are!
Jesus Christ!
OOOOHHHH
THAT AIN'T ME!
WHAT THE FUCK IS THIS? WHAT THE FUCK IS THIS DOING HERE?!?!
Seriously JESUS CHRIST
There's even professionals, trying to steal, my likeness.
*Creepy video intensifies*
I like how she painted the nostrils cause my nose is so fucking huge.
She had to paint nostrils to be bigger.
*snort*
WHAT!? THAT'S HOW SHE LOOKS LIKE?!
HOW? HOWW??
JESUS
Oh my god there's even one for Marzia
That's freaky man!
I can't... I can't.
*urp* Uh there's more!
Kandi....
Video: Hey guys, it's your friend Kandi!
There's no way she can look like me.
Ok?
So that was it guys...
WHAT THE FUCK
Pewdiepie tutorial! I can't hear with this thing on my ear.
Video: This is so...weird.
Ain't nothing weird here.
This is just me...
...and fake Pewdiepie reacting to an.. a girl...
...As fake Pewdiepie.
HOLY FU-
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOHHH
WHAT THE FUCK?
JEEEESUS CHRIST!
Oh...
My head...
I can't do this anymore...
I don't even know who I am anymore.
*Sad Music*
Anyway guys,
Thanks for watching this video!
Don't forget to give it a thumbs up-
TOP O' DA MORNIN' TO YA LADDIES! ©